How's this for a baptism by fire?
Just three days after being sworn into Congress
to represent Michigan's third district,
Republican freshmen, Peter Meijer, found himself
and his colleagues trapped without security
in the bowels of the Capitol building while a riot
that ultimately claimed five lives raged all around.
The following week he was one of just 10 Republicans
and the only first-term member of the GOP
who voted to impeach Donald Trump,
whom he had supported on the campaign trail.
Meijer's vote to impeach led to a narrowly failed censure vote
from his own state's GOP and immediate announcements
that he will be primaried in 2022.
The 33-year-old Iraq War veteran,
who says his military training helps him maintain focus,
is filling the seat vacated
by former Libertarian Party Congressman Justin Amash,
whose policy views he shares on a broad range of issues.
Meijer told Reason why he believes
in limited government, economic freedom, and individualism.
Why he's against out of control stimulus spending
and military adventurism, and how he plans to combat
the craziness he sees both on the right
and the left in the House of Representatives.
Representative Peter Meijer, thanks for talking to Reason.
Thank you for having me on Nick, a pleasure.
Let's start with, you are one of just 10 Republicans
in the House of Representatives
who voted to impeach Trump the second time,
and from what I've read
you're the only first term-er to do that.
Why did you vote to impeach Donald Trump,
your party's president?
Oh well, you know, that question is something
that I know a lot of my constituents have been asking.
I have had a number of town halls
and have heard a number of very impassioned opinions.
You know to me it was a pretty simple question of,
is the Republican Party, a party of rule of law?
A party that believes in accountability?
Or is it one that puts a personality, you know,
above principles?
The House's role in an impeachment is pretty narrow.
We look at the article, or articles in this case,
there was only one of impeachment that are laid
before us and have to make a judgment
if we believe it to be true and accurate.
And then if so,
if impeachment is a reasonable decision to make obviously,
this was one that was politically less than optimal.
I did not want in my first 10 days in office
to impeach a president of my own party,
but the fact of the matter is January 6th, and the assault
on the Capitol, would have never happened if it wasn't
for President Trump
propagating two lies.
One, that November 3rd was a landslide victory
for Donald Trump that was stolen.
And two, that January 6th was the day to stop the steal.
And those two lies,
which could have easily just faded away into nothing,
were continually amplified, legitimized,
and propagated by Donald Trump.
And it resulted in the deaths of five Americans,
the defiling of the seat of our democracy,
and frankly sent a message that we absolutely—
it sent a message that our first,
our Section One
powers can be undermined by the Executive.
So the third district of Michigan
is becoming the impeachment seat, right?
Because Justin Amash, who you replaced
when he chose not to run for reelection,
had voted to impeach Trump a couple of years ago
or whatever.
You like him, are taking a huge amount
of guff from constituents.
You mentioned some town halls and stuff, but so far
it's been announced one of your primary contenders
from this past election cycle said he's gonna primary you.
You may be censored by the state GOP.
This has happened to other republican congressmen who voted
to impeach members of Congress.
How do you feel about that?
You know, and I guess—
sorry to step in on my own question—
first, are you elected, like is your philosophy
that you're elected to reflect your conscience or that—
or the will of your constituents?
And then how are you gonna deal with it
if your own state party says, hey, you're
you're in big trouble buster?
Yeah, so my philosophy, to answer that question, is
that you're elected to exercise your judgment
and you're elected based off of the principles,
and the values that you espoused during the campaign.
But then ultimately, the job of a representative
is not just to represent the opinion of the mass
in a point in time, right? Or else what's the point?
I mean just take a poll, figure out where people are
and then have that be the direction.